[Music]
[Applause]
he's Peter shreer NFL Network good
morning football co-host and you can see
him there uh Monday through Friday at 7
Eastern uh Peter joins us on the program
now how real are these Caleb Williams
rumors or is it becoming a story of I I
there's five teams I'll go to I want a
piece of the team what do you make of
this or you know could he go back to
school feels like there's a lot going on
here well the NFL's monitoring this
stuff Dan obviously and that was the
first time I heard of the piece of the
team conversation that one just showed
up this week and I had not heard that
prior prior to this but the niil money
makes it different this is a State Farm
commercial where he's making seven
figures and he's at USC in La where he's
a bigger star than either quarterback of
the Chargers or the Rams and those guys
are pretty notable so this is a very
specific case but I don't think it's
going to be necessarily an odity moving
forward when these players are getting
paid in college where they don't have to
leave for the NFL or they can be a
little bit more selective he's the
number one Prospect but I think there's
gonna be another number one Prospect
next year the year after that and if
they're paid the way they are in college
right now what's the rush he's living a
pretty good life as is what about
Lincoln Riley possibly coaching in the
NFL as a package deal yeah I'd be
interested in that one obviously Lincoln
and him had the history with Oklahoma
and you know who else is with him in LA
right now Cliff kingsberry is coaching
the offense so he's getting NFL coaching
and he's getting his guy in Lincoln he's
getting it at that level but uh I'm not
saying it's a cautionary tale with some
of these college coaches the last couple
have been Rural and have been Urban
those are different styles than maybe uh
and Cliff was another one different
style than Lincoln Riley but I think the
NFL um we go through these waves of hot
college coach Chip Kelly let's bring in
that offense let's go I I'm not sure any
teams are are are running and rolling
out the red carpets for their college
coach right now as far as how the last
few have gone and there are some very
worthy candidates in the league I'm also
uh curious about the Cardinals as they
move forward Kyler Murray is going to
practice if you're Kyler Murray you want
to play because you want to win so they
don't draft your replacement but if
you're the front office do you want
Kyler Murray to play and maybe prevent
you from getting Caleb Williams and
restarting your
franchise what's interesting is you know
Kyler during the summer went to Norman
Oklahoma they were either honoring him
or they were putting a a statue of him
because he won the Heisman and all of
the Cardinals brass went the head coach
the president the GM the pr guy Mark
Dalton they all flew into Norman
Oklahoma and it was like one of these
moments where I'm like it's a Summer
Weekend uh the last thing I'm sure Monty
Austin Fort needs to be doing is flying
to Norman and I started texting people
in the Arizona organization and I was
like how's Kyler doing and they're like
he's been amazing like at the facility
warming up at the facility rehabbing and
I think there's this Vision that like oh
well Kyler's done because he heard his
knee I get the feeling they they double
down on Kyler they paid him his money
they fired the GM who who signed him to
that deal they fired the head coach who
who went and drafted him first overall
but like I get the feeling that
organization and Bidwell they are still
all in on Kyler so if they were to win a
couple games with Kyler and they missed
out on Caleb Williams I don't think
anyone would be shaking their fist I
think that building still believes in
them and to Kyler's credit The Narrative
at least internally has changed and
hopefully externally he'll be able to
show it on the field this season how
real is the Aaron roders coming back
late this season do you think very real
yeah very real he I've spoken to Salah
both good morning football and off the
Record and you know the key thing is
like these guys are not doctors these
are not individuals who are going to be
telling him what he cannot do um and
what he can do and there's not going to
be anyone there to say hey go out there
and play we want you out there Rogers is
wired differently as we know and he is
committed to getting back on that field
now he's got the top medical staff in
the world with ELR and of course the
Jets if they tell him that this is like
you know possibly can ruin your career
it can actually hurt you long term in
your life I would like to think cooler
heads are prevailing but like he is dead
set laser focused on getting back for
the end of the season and if the Jets
can just hang in there and make these
games competitive and if Zach Wilson can
do enough to get them into a position
where in late December early January
they're playing relevant football like I
would not in the slightest be shocked
Rogers seems to have a focus and the
doubters are feeding him in so many ways
in his life now I guess he's going to
defy science which I think uh wouldn't
be odd for Aaron Rogers in the last
couple years he kind of to go by the
beat of his own drum and thinks that his
body can will this thing to happen and
here we go who gets
traded I think there's interesting names
so like I I would have told you two days
ago and I'm not trying to say oh you
know Pat me on the back but like Hardman
was a name that hasn't been playing uh
you looked at Frank Clark in Denver that
wasn't working out and of course Randy
Gregory what was going on there in
Denver as well but I would look at
players who are making big
money who not necessarily are getting
big snaps so again Carl Lawson a player
in the Jets they've got a huge defensive
lineman rotation Carl Lawson can still
play good football hasn't been in the
mix necessarily with that you look at
some of the running backs in the league
you look at guys that you know maybe ran
Penny up there in Philadelphia who was a
big signing it's a big but they got
their guys DeAndre Swift and gainwell
have been the guys do you ship him off
to a contender instead say well look we
don't have the best use for him for what
he's getting snap wise I hate saying
names I name those two because often
they don't get traded and you're like
well what the heck you said no but those
are the players that are looking to be
moved then you look at teams you look at
Denver you know in in Denver situation a
lot of these guys you know they've been
making big money with different people
bringing them in you look at Carolina
okay well what can we ship off we've
done it in the past like is Brian Burns
available well surely looks like a silly
move to trade Christian mcaffry a couple
years ago are they gon to make that
mistake twice and trade a star player
and say well we were done for the season
uh big money big snaps and for teams
that aren't necessarily contending those
are the guys I would Circle what about
Derk Henry that possibility or Devonte
Adams I don't think Titans view like
they're out of this thing Devonte Adams
they you know I see the Instagram post
he's writing the ilad on an inter
Instagram post they won the last two
games so like the the Raiders they they
still think they're in this thing and
he's a great player now look at like
Hunter Renfro in two years with Josh
McDaniels hasn't been a focus so it's
maybe Hunter Ren for a possibility yes I
don't think Devonte Adams another one
the cousins thing I reported this on Fox
NFL kickoff last week yes in fantasy
football and on paper like Kirk Cousins
he's in his final year of his contract
and he's making 35 million and you look
at what's left and it's actually not
that bad a contract for a contender but
the Vikings still believe they're in it
and the Vikings still believe that Kirk
is their best option at quarterback and
after beating the Bears they don't see
this thing as done deals so they're
looking to be competitive so it's I
don't think you're going to get a star
player like Derek Henry or Kurt Cousins
in the next couple of weeks he hosts the
season with Peter shreer podcast
available wherever you listen to your
podcast also he'll be a contestant next
week on Celebrity Jeopardy did you
already did you already tape it yes have
you done it uh no no um I I have no
interest in doing it why
not I just I have I don't know you know
when they were asking if you wanted to
host Jeopardy they were looking for a
new host there I I turned I told him I I
didn't want to do that I see I I would
think you would be incredible in that
role I had the opportunity had Alex tbec
retired when they thought he was going
to retire that I was going to be offered
the job and that it didn't happen I did
uh Sports Jeopardy which I loved but no
I I I don't want to get on there because
you're going to miss a a a question and
people are going to go how could you
miss that but when you're up there
fighting for survival and I would see
this with these contestants man and you
would be it'd be the most obvious
question you'll go oh no BL yes did you
have a moment did you have a moment
multiple but let me tell you something
unlike you I am a glory hog and fame
love being on TV and thought that
this was gonna be like look the writers
were on strike the actors were on strike
Peter trigger for Celebrity Jeopardy I
don't think that's coming around too
often uh so I ran at the opportunity
okay flew out to LA can I tell you it
was the coolest experience in my life it
films next W it's Rec it's airing next
Wednesday at eight o'clock Eastern and I
want everyone to watch either you like
me or you hate me you're gonna enjoy the
experience but let me tell you the crazy
part about it so I had answers but no
one tells you about the buzzer it's all
about the buzzer so here's the rules Ken
Jennings gives you the clue and say the
answer is like this wide receiver you
know caught a 100 passes for the Rams a
couple years ago and he says it like
that so I'm like who is Cooper Cup who
is Cooper cup but it you're not allowed
to buzz in until after he finishes the
clue and if you buzz before the clue
you're locked out for like five seconds
so if you see anyone on J going like
this like frantically like it's because
they buzzed early so win or lose or
whatever the buzzer is most of the skill
set here and once you get that Rhythm
down it becomes a little easier I'll
tell you I went up against MEA svino
who's won an Oscar mhm and they you know
Mira Serino is a huge actress she's you
know Rome and Michelle and mighty afite
her father's Paul Shino what do you
think her reaction was when she comes
into Celebrity Jeopardy and she sees
Peter shreer host of cable television's
good morning football wait that sounded
like that would have been a question by
you know or an answer um who is Peter
shreer nobody knows I'm sure I'm sure
Mera is watching good morning mea is
here to watched the Jaguars o line talk
this morning um it was awesome they were
cool Ken Jennings was cool uh it was a
once in a-lifetime experience I cannot
reveal how I did okay but I wasn't
embarrassed I'll tell you that did they
have some football questions for you
there was there was a couple and I will
tell you I was making sure that I got
those and I was right but the buzzer
screwed me a couple times and people are
probably gonna be like how does he not
know that but this is what I was told
that one of the contestants we had for
uh Sports Jeopardy he said he studied my
Cadence in how I delivered the clue
because he wanted to know when he could
buzz in cuz you're right it's all about
timing when you see fritzy it fritzy
would be you know slamming it down when
the Dan were on yes and and this guy
said he studied my Cadence of how I
delivered a clue to know the timing and
then and he was unbelievable he would
buzz in and the other guys are you could
see them just slamming their thumbs down
because they were shut out couldn't get
in dude you would have loved this so I
got told like eight days in advance that
I'm sure someone dropped out they're
like do you want to go I'm like yes
so I get on the plane and if someone
told you like you're on Jeopardy
tomorrow like what would you I swear I
was on the plane like Southwest
Southwest flight like you know boarding
Group B and I'm like on Wikipedia with a
jankee Wi-Fi like state
capitals clouds like I might no cumulous
Cloud I was
just I looked up bonapart like give me
some bonapart facts let's get Napolean
invol none of those topics came out it
was like words that start with the
letter H you know like none thing you
could ever so I started studying US
presidents like none of it mattered none
of it mattered uh it was like when I
hosted the Olympics and I thought God I
got to know every Olympian I have to
know everything about everything and it
I it it was ruining my experience until
Al Michaels goes Dan my man just know
the next 15 minutes that's it that's it
don't know everything just know the next
15 minutes of what you're covering I go
thank you Al thank you uh the funniest
thing just real quick you like this she
she's got against me Cino I'm like all
right actress I Google her went to
Harvard and is an ambassador for the
UN poll question Satan would you give
that to uh our celebrity here yes Peter
shreer who is Peter shreer correct uh
let's see we have Trevor Lawrence is a
dot dot dot top 10 quarterback somewhat
disappointing go top 10 quarterback they
won a couple games in a row they've won
three games in a row he's done he's won
a playoff game like yeah he's fine he
he's not in the conversation with the
other guys just yet but we've been
watching him since high school we've
been hearing about him since high school
and for him not to fall in his face is
an achievement in itself and I think he
makes the Jaguars relevant from December
and January so yeah I'm going to say the
first part top 10 quarterback sure how
threatening are the
Saints I don't know they're like Jackel
and Hyde you know they beat the the the
snot out of the Patriots and then they
lose a tough one in Houston they're a
nice team and they're probably gonna win
that Division I would think that them
and Tampa are gonna be in the final
conversation but like I are you going
into the super doome is hard I don't
know if you're you know shaking in your
boots in the playoffs if you're Niners
are an Eagles team and Derek Carr and
Dennis Allen are coming to
town good luck uh on Celebrity Jeopardy
well you already know how you did but uh
you know we're we're with you 100 110%
we're with you yeah now some of us are
rooting for Mira svino just want to let
you know yeah she brings it no names no
names here but just some people secretly
are like I'm not rooting for shreer
that's it Ser I understand um my best to
the crew there at good morning football
you're man you that's Peter shrier he's
uh one of the co-hosts there good
morning football Monday through Friday
at 7 Eastern very entertaining show you
do a great job also is podcast the
season with Peter shreer you spelled it
s c r a g r podcast available wherever
you get your podcast and also he's a
celebrity on Celebrity Jeopardy